foreign
what's up
this decision is extremely unpopular
among Afghan and even within the Taliban
leadership it has been criticized by the
entire Islamic worlds
it has undermined the talban's
relationship with the International
Community but it remains in force
causing damage today that will be filled
along into the future
[Music]
there is tension within the Taliban but
the hand is not talking to the mouth and
even the people who oppose this decision
have been very passive so there is an
argument out there that says maybe it's
good that such a ban happens maybe then
the less conservative among the Taliban
have nothing else to lose and they can
go out and try to strong arm the Amir
um but I mean if they didn't do it so
far what makes us believe that they will
do so now
foreign
[Music]